[تصفيق]
تظاهرات في الاحواز والتبريز بطهران
والعمله الايرانيه تنهار مجددا تحت ضغط
الاحتجاجات والعقوبات
انقطاع الكهرباء
الروسيه ومسؤول موال لموسكو ويتهم القوات
الاوكرانيه بقصف محيطي
اسود الاطلس يستعدون للقاء الديوك بعد فوز
فرنسا على انجلترا واحتفالات في باريس
والمدن المغربيه
[موسيقى]
احييكم واهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه صباح الخير سنبداها
من ايران حيث خرجت تظاهرات الليليه في
الاحواز والعاصمه طهران فيما نظم مواطنون
في مدينه تبريز شمال
للمظاهرات الشعبيه في البلاد
والبادي
[موسيقى]
امبارح في الميه السقوط
اثناء زيارتي ممثله قم في البرلمان
الايراني مجبتي ذو النور الجامعه تقم
سالته طالبه عن سبب اعدام محسن شكاري
بتهمه اغلاق الشارع وان كانت عقوبته اغلاق
الشارع هي الاعدام وعندما ابتسم ذنوبي
وبخطه الطالبه بالقول الا تخجلون تعلمون
ابناء الناس ثم تبتسمون
[موسيقى]
خزانات
وزيره الداخليه نانسي فجر في رساله عبر
الفيديو عن تضمنها مع الانتفاضه الايرانيه
وداعتذر الجميع للدفاع عن الشعب الايراني
كما توجهت للمواطنين من اصول الايرانيه
وقالت لهم ان المانيا ستكون صوتهم وانها
ستؤمن الحمايه لهما
ترجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى مستوى
المنخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع استمرار
الاضطرابات وتزايدي عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه للاجراءات الامنيه
الصارمه التي تتخذها ايران
وعلاقاتها مع روسيا وجرى بيع الدولار بما
يصل الى
370,000,200 ريال ايراني في السوق غير
الرسميه بينما كان
367,300 ريال ايراني الجمعه وفقا لموقع
الصرف الاجنبي بومبا
وفقد الريال اكثر من 13% من قيمته منذ
دلاع الاحتجاجات في البلاد بعد مقتل الشاب
مساء مين في السادسه عشر من سبتمبر
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
اكثر من مليون ونصف المليون شخصا في منطقه
عوديسا بجنوب اوكرانيا انقطعت عنهم
الكهرباء بعد ضربات بطائره مسيره روسيه
على نظام توليد الكهرباء في تلك المنطقه
اشاره رئيس بلديه اوديسا الاوكرانيه جناده
الى ان الكهرباء انقطعت عن جميع مرافق
البنيه التحتيه غير الحيويه في مدينه
واديسا بعد اطلاق روسيا طائرات مسيره لضرب
مشات الطاقه في حين يتضرر ايضا جزء كبير
من المنطقه المحيطات
الخناف انا طائرات مسيره ايرانيه من طراز
136 اصابت منشاتين للطاقه في منطقه اوديسا
وانا نشرت اداره المدينه بيانا جاء فيها
ان الضربات الروسيه اصابه خطوط ومعدات
الرئيسيه لنقل الطاقه
اتهمت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في دونيت
القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف مركز المدينه ب 20
صاروخ جراد فيما ادى قصف اوكرانيه
بالصواريخ هاي مارس في مدينه مليوتوبيل
بمنطقه زاكوريجيا الى مقتل شخصين واصابه
10 اخرين وقال يبكيني القائم بعمل حكم
منطقه ذا فويس جهه التي ضمتها موسكو في
وقت سابق انه يتم تقديمه كل المساعده
الطبيه اللازمه للمصابين الذين سقطوا في
احد المطاعم المنطقه
بينما يرجى الاتحاد الاوروبي مفاوضات
التحديد سقف سعر الغاز محاولا توصل
الاتفاق نيوردي جميع الاطراف اعترض بعض
اعترضت بعض الدول الاعضاء على السعر الذي
تتم مناقشته مطالبه بتخفيضه بشكل اكبر
عصفوراني بحجر واحد عقوبه تضغط على روسيا
وتخفيف اعداء عن المواطن الاوروبي هذا ما
يحاول الاتحاد الاوروبي للقيام به بتحديد
سقف لسعر الغازي في اوروبا ويجتمع وزراء
الطاقه للتوصل الى سعر ثابت يخفف وطات
ازمه الطاقه التي اشتاحت القاره العجوز
كذوبعه غير متوقعه اثر الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا الا ان الدول الاعضاء ليست كلها
محشوره في زاويه الضيقه للغازي الروسي
بعضها تعتمد على الغاز الروسي بشكل اكبر
من الاخر ما يجعل وضعها اسوا من دول اخرى
فلا مقارنه بين المانيا التي تستورد 55%
من غازها من روسيا وفرنسا التي اكتفت
بسبعه في المئه فقط معتمده على مصادر اخرى
كالنرويج
ما اداب اثنتي عشره دوله من دول الاعضاء
الى المطالبه بخفض كبير لسقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يتفاوض عليه
[موسيقى]
لتبقى العقده الاكبر في الاتحاد الان ليس
الرقم بل ايجاد اليه لارضاء جميع الاعضاء
في ظل اعتماد الكتله على قاعده الاجماع
التي لا تحتمل اعتراض عضو واحد
عمليه تحديد سقف السعر تغضب موسكو
كان قد صرح ان بلاده سترفض بيع منتجاتها
من المحروقات لاي دوله تطبق سقف السعري
شتاء بارد دائما في اوروبا الا ان الحرب
الروسيه الساخنه زادت من برودته بالرغم من
ان الدول الاوروبيه مثل المانيا تؤكد ان
مخزوناتها تكفيها حتى نهايه الفصل الا
انها تشدد على ترشيد الاستهلاك الى عمر
العربيه
سنتابع نشرتنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
تويتر ستزيدوا اسعار الاشتراك بخدمه تويتر
بلو على اجهزه ابل بدءا من يوم الاثنين
فليحه السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيس
الوزراء اللبناني نجيب ميقاتي في الرياض
وجرى خلال اللقاء استعراض اوجه العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين واكد ولي العهد حرس
المملكه على امن لبنان واستقراره وعلى
استمرار الدعم الانساني الذي تقدمه
المملكه للشعب اللبنانيه وعبر ميقاتي يعني
الشكر والتقدير لمواقف المملكه تجاه لبنان
ودورها في ارساء المصالحه اللبنانيه كما
اكد التزام الحكومه اللبنانيه كل الخطوات
التي تمنع الاساءه الى السعوديه ودول مجلس
التعاون وتم تاكيد على اهميه انتخاب رئيس
لبنان
تنفيذ الاصلاحات التي يتطلع لها الشعب
اللبناني والمجتمع الدوليه
كم استقبل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان في الرياض رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
الليبي محمد المنيفي واجر خلال اللقاء
استعراض مستجدات الاوضاع على الساحه
الليبيه وبحث افاق تعاون بين البلدين وعدد
من المسائل ذات الاهتمام المشترك
الى اخبارك كاس العالم حيث اقصد فرنسا
حامله اللقب المنتخب الانجليزي ضمن الدوري
ربع النهائي فرنسا تتواجه المنتخب المغربي
في نصف النهائي وذلك بعد ان استطاع اسود
الاطلس الفوز على البرتغال والصعود
التاريخيه للمربع الذهبي من كاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والان الى التقرير الرياضي مع زميله
ليليان
تحيه رياضيه اهلا بكم الى المجاز الرياضيه
حقق منتخب المغرب مفاجاه مدويه جديده وكتب
التاريخ بالتاهل لنصف نهائي كاس العالم
بالفوز بهدف من دون مقابل على البرتغال في
دور الثمانيه سجل يوسف النصيري مهاجم
المغرب هدفا المباراه الوحيد بضربه راس من
مدى قريب بعد تمرير عرضيه من يحيى عطيه
الله قبل نهايه الشوط الاول بدقائق وتالق
ياسين بونو حارس المغرب في انقادي مرماه
من سلسله من الفرس ليقض بلاده الى انجازا
تاريخي حيث اصبح المغرب اول منتخب عربي او
افريقي يصل الى نصف نهائي العرص العالمي
سيلعب المغرب الذي كان يشارك في دوله
ثمانيه لكاس العالم لاول مره في تاريخه
سيلعب امام منتخب فرنسا الفائز على نظيره
الانجليزي
اوكي يعني
لقد دخلنا التاريخ كاول منتخب افريقيا
يصلوا للنصف النهائي في كاس العالم اتمنى
ان لا نكون اخر منتخب من القاره يصل لهذا
الدور بالنسبه لحاله الصحيه سنرى غدا
الفحوصات وان كان يجب ان العب بقدم واحده
في نصف النهائي فساقوم بذلك
الفوز بالمباراه
احنا بالنسبه للخلطه اللي قلت احنا احنا
عائله والحمد لله كتشوفها في همم في
الملعب لما بيتصابلك لاعب والحمد لله
بيدخل الاخر بيؤدي بالشكل جيد وهذا هو هذا
هو الفريق اللي الحمد لله بيحقق نتائج
كبيره الحمد لله
فك عن
استحق كاس العالم
المغرب كما تغنوا باسماء اللاعبين والمدرب
وليد الرجراجي الذي قاد المنتخب لهذا
الانجاز التاريخي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا جانب الاخر اعتلت الحسره هو الحزن جوه
الجماهير البرتغاليه التي شهدت منتخب
بلادها وهو يودع البطوله على يد المنتخب
المغربي بعد الخساره بهدف من دون رضوى تعد
هذه البطوله الاخيره لكريستيانو رونالدو
الذي علقت عليه جماهير العديد من الامال
في السنوات الماضيه لمساعده منتخب بلاده
للظفر باغلى بطوله في العالم على مستوى
المنتخب
وصل المنتخب الفرنسي طريقه نحو الحفاظ على
لقبه بطلا لكاس العالم بعد فوزه على
المنتخب الانجليزي بهدفين مقابل هدف
واحدتاهل نصف نهائي لمواجهه المنتخب
المغربي سدد اوريون شاوميني تسديده قويه
سكنت شباك المنتخب الانجليزي تقدم به
منتخب بلاده في الشوط الاول قبل ان يعيد
هاري كين انجلترا الى المباراه لتسجيل هدف
التعادل من ضربه جزاء وتقدم المنتخب
الفرنسي مجددا بهدف سجله وهدافه الاول
اوليفياجيرو وسنحط فرصه اخرى
ثانيه من ضربه جزاء لكنه سددها فوق
العارضه لتنتهي المباراه
[تصفيق]
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار المونديال شكرا
لمتابعتكم تحياتي
الجيش اليمني بسقوط قتلى من جماعه الحوثي
في الشبكات مع الجيش في محافظه الضاله
جنوب اليمن واضاف الجيش ان عناصر جماعه
الحوت حولت التسلل باتجاه مواقع
جبهه الفاخر غربه
لكنها قوات الجيش احبطتها واجبرتها على
الفرار بعد تكبيرها خسائر
وضعوا الانساني ينحرج في محافظه تعز التي
تعيش حصارا تفرده منشيئه الحوت منذ عده
سنوات جهات حقوقيه عداءنه الممارسات التي
تطال نحو خمسه ملايين نسمه يسخنون
المحافظه
الضوء على جرائم الميليشيات الحوثيه
واستعرض التقرير يبين طرق تحويل المساعدات
الامميه لدعم الحوثيين
قطع مليشيات الحوثي الطرق في حصارها لتعز
هو اشبه بقطع شرايين المحافظه والذي يتسبب
في موت بطيء لخمسه ملايين نسمه في حصار
دام ثمان سنوات ترفض الميليشيات وضع حد
الله الامر الذي تسبب في تعطيل تجديد
الهدنه الامميه مما يهدد مساعي السلام
الاوضاع الخنيقه في المحافظه ادت الى
تدهور الحاله الاقتصاديه وكانت سببا في
كارثه انسانيه
وتمنوا الميليشيات الحوثيه في ان تجعلها
اكثر سوءا بقصف الاحياء السكنيه وقتل
المدنيين
سنوات من الحصار نتيجتها حوادث سير مميته
بسبب وعوره الطرق في مداخل تعز مما يزيد
الوضع الانساني ماساويه
اما استخدام الحوثيين للالغام التي يحرمها
القانون الدولي فما هو الا وجه اخر
لسوداويه المخططات الحوثيه وما تحمله
لليمن واليمنيين من دمار وخراب الاسم
المماسي العربيه
استهدف قصف جوي تركيب مواقع على حسب
العمال الكردستاني في دهوك شمال العراق
وقال مصر امنيا الطائرات التركيه قصفت
مناطق مطله على احدى قرى قضاء العماديه
بمحافظه
حجم الاضرار الناجمه عن القصف بدون ذلك
طلب مسؤول بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
المجتمع الدولي باغلاق المجال الجوي امام
المقاتلات التركيه مشيرا الى ان السلاح
الجو التركي
في سياق اخر سجلت الليره السوريه تذهبن
قياسيا جديدا في السوق السوداء لتتخطى
عتبه السته الاف مقابل الدولار
[موسيقى]
اصلا وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه بيانا
اعلنت فيه انا وزير الخارجيه ليس يلقي
خطابا يوم غد الاثنين يشدد فيه على وجوب
ان تنظر المملكه المتحده الى ما هو ابعد
من خلفائها التقليديين من اجل تطوير
الشركات مع دول الناشئه في افريقيا واسيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه
[موسيقى]
تسلمت الولايات المتحده المواطنه
الموريتانيه فواز ولد احمد الذي حكم عليه
بالاعدام في باماكو عاصمه مالي بعد
اعترافه بتخطيطه وتنفيذ الهجمات الثلاثه
القاتله في العام 2015 والتي اسفرت عن
مقتل 38 شخصا وقالت وزاره العدل الامريكيه
ان المواطن الموريتاني وجهه سته ابتهامات
من بينها قتل الامريكيه عن التدتار وتامر
لتقديم دعم لتنظيم القاعده والمرابطين
الذين تصنفهما الولايات المتحده على انهما
ارهابيان
تستعد منصه تويتر بدءا من يوم غد الاثنين
لزياده اسعار الاشتراك بخدمتها المدفوعه
تويتر بلو على تطبيق اجهزه ابل وهو ما
يعني تحميل المستخدم تكلفه الحصه التي
تقطعها ابل من المدفوعات ومن المفترض ان
يتم رفع السعر الى 11$ اذا تمت عمليه
الشراء من خلال تطبيق على اجهزه ايفون
وايباد في حين سيتم تخفيض السعر الى 8
دولارات اذا ما تم الاشتراك بها عبر موقع
الويب وتهدف هذه الخطوه الى تقليل تاثير
اقتطاع ابل لنسبتها التي تصل الى 30% من
كل عمليتي دفعا تجري داخل التطبيقات
رفض الامير البريطاني هاري وزوجته ميغان
انتقادات لمسلسل وثائقي عن حياتهما وذلك
في بيان اصدره المتحدث باسمه ما قال فيه
ان الزوجين لم يذكر ابدا ان الخصوصيه كانت
سببا للتخلي عن واجباته مع الملكيه
[موسيقى]
نختم من الفضاء حيث من المقرر ان تطلق
اليابان اليوم اول مركبه فضائل القمر من
قاعده
الامريكيه شركه سبيس اليابانيه الخاصه
ستطلق المركبه
بعد تاجيلها مرتين بسبب عمليات تفتيش على
الصاروخ الذي يحمل المركبات
شركه سبيس الى وضعيه قمر صناعي صغير تابع
لاداره الطيران والفضاء في مدارس حول
القمر للبحث عن رواسب المياه
ختام نذكر بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
تظاهرات في الاحواز والتبريز وطهران
والعمله الايرانيه تنهار مجددا تحت ضغط
الاحتياجات والعقبات
انقطاع الكهرباء
الاوكرانيه بقصف محيطي زبوريده
اسود الاطلس يستعدون للقائد ديوك بعد فوز
فرنسا على انجلترا واحتفالات في باريس
والمدن المغربيه
اشكر لكم طب المتابعه اقعد والتقيكم بعد
قليل فيه نشره اخباريه دائما ابقى معنا في
امان الله
[موسيقى]